we just got samsung's new 12.4 inch tab
s8 plus and we're gonna see does it beat
out apple's 12.9 inch ipad pro while
saving you hundreds of dollars we are
going to be comparing everything from
the designs the displays the performance
of the cpu and the graphics the cameras
the speakers and much more one thing
that shocks me is just how slim this box
is i'm guessing that samsung is no
longer including a charger not only with
their phones following apple but with
their tablets as well actually let's
check that
yep no charger whatsoever that's kind of
crazy because even apple they are still
including a charger with their ipad
now this thing in the hand feels very
very slim let's pull it out of that bag
all right nice and clean look on the
back we do have a couple logos and then
this black little uh stripe here this
little insert and that is to charge and
attach your s pen the tab is slightly
thinner than the ipad but about 20
lighter because overall it has a smaller
footprint and a smaller battery inside
and in the hand you definitely do notice
it but it's not a huge difference one
huge advantage of the tab is the fact
that we have a micro sd card slot in
here
if i can get it out that is and it
allows up to a one terabyte sd card
which won't be as fast as internal
memory but it'll save you a lot of money
setting it up we have an option of what
authentication we want to use so we do
have facial recognition but it is
nowhere as secure as apple's face id so
most people are going to be using the
fingerprint scanner testing it out it
does seem like the little area for the
fingerprint unlocking is smaller and
more sensitive than samsung's s22 phones
and it's a little bit less responsive as
well but it does still work and you can
use it with the screen shut off now on
the ipad of course we have face id so
you can tap and just slide up and the
benefit of face id is that when you open
up an application you don't have to take
your hand off and put your fingerprint
there it will just automatically
authenticate i think overall it is more
convenient now we have heard some great
things about the speakers in samsung's
latest tablets so let's go ahead and
compare them both have a quad speaker
setup i'm going to go into the menu and
make sure that dolby atmos is enabled
and let's go ahead and take a listen
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
all right guys well you heard it for
yourselves that's a pretty big
difference the tab does sound pretty
decent but the ipad takes it to a whole
nother level in terms of richness and
base let's just hear that one more time
loudness is not a massive difference
this ipad is a little bit louder just
the highs aren't as sharp but that
deepness of the bass and the richest of
the mids are definitely better now what
we will have to see is how the ipad
compares to the tab s8 ultra that is the
larger 14 inch size and we will be
having that comparison coming up here
very very soon so make sure you guys
subscribe down below if you guys want to
see that and if you want to help us
reach our goal of 1 million subscribers
and now let's talk about displays
because we have a ton of differences now
the pixels per inch they are very close
and the size is also very similar 12.4
compared to 12.9 but as you guys see for
yourselves because of the difference in
aspect ratio the ipad actually has about
15 percent more screen real estate now
the technologies are also different we
have oled over here compared to mini led
so let's look at all of those
differences and what that means in the
real world we're going to start out with
reflectivity and as you guys could see
the ola display even though it's
supposed to have pure blacks it looks
gray because the coatings on this
display are nowhere near apple's
anti-reflectivity coatings and now
getting into brightness i have both set
to about 20
and with oleds you do have that
flickering which for video cameras they
look like lines and that is something
that bugs some people we'll also talk
about blooming here in just a bit but
now let's go ahead and maximize the
brightness i adjusted that top camera so
it's not blown out and you can see that
the ipad is brighter by about 100 nits
or so when we max out the screens now
that does not tell the whole story
because we also have differences in
viewing angles and when we're playing
back hdr video this ipad is able to
reach up to a thousand six hundred nits
whereas the tab s8 plus reaches up to
only 500. because of this the ipad
provides a much brighter image with
bright specular highlights that really
pop because of the mini led screen and
even though the ipad does have a more
square aspect ratio when you're watching
videos the actual viewable size is about
the same and even though ola does have
pure blacks because of the pretty
reflective display they look a lot more
gray than the ipad so i gotta be honest
going into this i did think that the tab
would be better for watching movies
simply because of the aspect ratio being
better for videos and i thought the
speakers are going to do better than
they did and then also the fact that
it's oled and but in reality because of
things we just covered the ipad is a
better movie watching experience with
those better speakers as well now the
one downfall of the mini led screen is
blooming i just put into the toughest
situation possible our brightness is
maxed out with this black scene and we
do see some glow around some of these
highlights and also the menu bars as
well when they pop up and it's turned up
all the way now the tabs ola display
does not have that
so in these crazy scenarios it is better
for that but then you don't get the same
specular highlights as well now it's
really up to you what bugsy more
blooming if you have the brightness
turned up with hdr in completely dark
rooms or super dark rooms or dealing
with not as bright of a screen and
having a lot more reflectivity in normal
lighting or outdoors both of these
displays are 120 hertz panels and i'm
glad that samsung out of the box has a
set to high to give you that really nice
smoothness but you can also switch it to
standard if you want to save battery
life now it's interesting because last
time with the tab s7 they had adaptive
refresh rate which would change your
refresh rate to save battery but also be
smooth just like apple's pro motion now
apple has no toggle it's all automatic
and you always get the best performance
and mix of battery life now one thing i
love is that samsung includes their s
pen in the box you don't have to spend
129 dollars more to buy it after you buy
your ipad so that is great and i also do
like that it's lighter it is smaller
it's just more compact overall but then
when we compare the performance even
though both are 120 hertz the ipad has
no delay whatsoever whereas the s pen
does have delay if you're drawing faster
now with that said most people probably
won't care about this too much unless
you're professional or you got to do
something super quick and as far as the
way these attach the s pen attaches on
the back here which i don't think is as
convenient because it's easier to pop
off unless you're using that case
whereas the apple pencil it attaches at
the top so it's more out of your way and
now we have to cover the keyboard cases
and decks apple's magic keyboard is
definitely nicer than what samsung
offers the build quality is better the
trackpad it has an even click feel all
around and we have an extra charging
port that leaves your usb-c port on the
ipad available for thunderbolt
connections or usb or anything you
really need as for the tab sa it uses
the same keyboard cases as the tab s7
and in front of me i have the regular
one that comes in 160 bucks and that is
because samsung is giving these away for
free which is a great deal now this one
does not have the trackpad built in so
you have to use a mouse or just a
touchscreen but the keyboard feel and
the typing does feel quite nice now this
one is not adjustable like the ipad is
or the other keyboard cover but it does
have a little slot on the back here to
keep your pen secure and allow it to
magnetize and a really cool feature is
that we have another area right here
that will keep your s pen secure without
adding the extra bulk on the back like
their more expensive 230 dollar keyboard
cover will now apples comes in at
350 dollars which is just mind-numbingly
expensive for a keyboard case so even
though it is nice you're definitely
paying for it now the killer feature of
the samsung is dex which turns your
tablet into pretty much a whole regular
desktop operating system that you would
have with a laptop now the ipad does
have multitasking but it is nothing like
what dax offers which really lets you do
pretty much anything you want now i
hammered apple really hard with my
review of the ipad pro with m1 processor
because the performance is there but
ipad os is still so locked down with
blatant software issues or limitations
that apple doesn't want to address but
with dex you have full control you can
even connect this to a display hook up a
keyboard and a mouse and use it like an
actual computer and another killer
feature with the tab s8 plus
is the fact that the camera is
positioned horizontally the way you
would want to be positioned if you're
using a keyboard case if you're in a
zoom conference or really anything else
like that even playing games with the
ipad your camera is off to the side so
if you're sitting here talking to
somebody you're looking at your screen
you're basically looking like you're not
paying attention to them at all i've
seen it in the news it is very very
weird whereas samsung they position
theirs correctly so if you're looking at
your screen you're looking at who you're
talking to now both of these do have a
center stage or auto framing like
samsung calls it samsung's does have a
little bit more of a delay but maybe
they will improve it now with that said
let's go ahead and just compare the
video quality and the microphone quality
this is the video in microphone quality
with samsung's galaxy tab s8 plus in a
room with some hvac noise and this is
the video in microphone quality with
apple's m1 ipad pro sitting directly in
front of me in a room with some hvac
noise you guys let me know which one
looked better and which one sounded
better down below and now let's compare
the performance the ipad has apple's
legendary m1 processor whereas the
samsung has snapdragon's latest
uh 8 gen 1 cpu let's go ahead and test
out the ssds first because both of these
have 256 gigs of ssd and 8 gigs of ram
alright wow i was not expecting that big
of a difference
the ipad has incredibly fast storage so
you're definitely getting what you're
paying for as far as the read speed it's
2.25 times faster over double and the
right speeds are literally triple the
speed so definitely some very fast ssd
storage in the ipad and now let's test
out the cpu performance both of these
have eight core cpus and they both have
eight gigs of ram now we already tested
this processor in samsung's s22 ultra
phone i'm just hoping we get some more
performance because this time it is in a
tablet instead of a much smaller phone
of course we know the m1 is an absolute
beast but let's see what performance we
get all right we have our results
and it looks like the tab s8 plus
actually might be a little bit slower
than the samsung
phone
as far as single core score we have a
difference of 38
in favor of the ipad but in multi-core
score
over double
2.15
basically just blows it away in terms of
performance now the question is up to
you do you need that much performance
the main benefit is being able to use
this ipad two three four five years from
now and still have enough performance on
top of that the really nice decoders
encoders if you want to work with video
it's gonna keep up with what you want
and of course better software updates
whereas this one right now the samsung
can handle most things that you throw at
it and it's gonna not have any issues
but a couple of years from now you will
start to notice that you would want more
performance now let's go ahead and see
what this means in the real world this
is gonna test how snappy and responsive
the ipads are and look at that
wow that is two and a half times
more runs per minute so definitely that
single quart performance and multi-core
is amazing with the ipad but what about
graphics performance i'm going to run
3dmark's excellent wildlife extreme test
in the unlimited mode that way we don't
have any frame rate caps or anything
like that the results are in and once
again we kind of have a slaughter with
the graphics in the latest snapdragon
being a big improvement compared to the
last models but still nowhere near the
performance of the m1 which gets a score
of over 5 000 compared to 2
200 so 13 frames per second compared to
30.
massive difference in performance so
overall no matter what you're doing
the ipad is just so much more powerful i
just wish that apple would give it
proper software or proper applications
like final cut logic to make use of all
this power now of course there are still
good apps on the app store but the ipad
is a lot more locked down than the
samsung whereas the samsung just cannot
touch the ipad in terms of performance
now as far as cameras we already covered
the ultrawide front-facing ones but
here's an image you guys let me know
which one looks best and then on the
back both of these have two lenses they
have a standard lens for most of your
shots scanning documents things like
that and an ultrawide lens as well so
you guys can see the quality differences
right there now personally cameras don't
really matter to me that much but the
ipad also has that lidar sensor for
augmented reality which the samsung does
not have and as far as battery life this
thing just came out so we haven't tested
it but i looked online it looks like
you're gonna get about one to two hours
more battery life with the ipad just
because you have that 120 hertz pro
motion display that can vary
the refresh rate and that definitely
saves power for the system and the
battery is a little bit more powerful as
well and then the m1 has four efficiency
cores so that gives it a leg up now you
guys saw all of those tests
in the beginning i have to be honest i
thought that the ipad is just so
expensive you're paying you know a
little bit over 200 more to initially
purchase it and that's without the pen
but after doing this comparison a lot of
things are better the speakers are
better your display with the mini led
600 nits is better your ssd's a lot
faster the performance of the cpu
graphics that's much faster over twice
as fast you also have face id so overall
it is the better tablet it's a shame
that it's locked down like i said so if
you need something that doesn't have a
lot of performance or as much you don't
need that but you want more flexibility
the android is the way to go but the
ipad just offers a lot more performance
and features for the money as far as
hardware and it's going to get better
resale you guys let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
below go ahead and click that circle
above to subscribe if you guys want to
see the same comparison but with the tab
s8 ultra that we will be coming out with
very soon check out one of those videos
right there this has been max and i'll
see you in the next video
[Music]